it's time to take the classic advice
column and give it up to the old drew's
new spin this is
ask a desk spurt oh no it's it again
well as we like to say here on the show
we are not experts but we're desk perts
if you're in a pickle we would like to
get involved and today in honor of
beauty week we're tackling your beauty
questions so let's get started with our
first question where's yolanda
hi
welcome to the show
so how can we help you i really do not
know how to
do my eyebrows groom them i really love
some tips on how to do them
oh you got good brows too well i went to
the salon one time and they snatched off
one and now i'm eyebrows shy so you're
going to take your pencil
and i like to draw in
the brow of my choice
and you want to fill in any holes by the
way i gotta tweeze i can tell you that
much
when you draw in and this doesn't have
to be even an everyday ritual but if
you're looking to tweeze
draw the brow of your dreams with a very
precision tip pencil
and then whatever hairs are falling
outside that line those are the ones you
want to grab with a tweezer
and then once you tweeze and you get
that shape i tend to love taking
something that has a little bit of
product and a little bit of a spoolie
now a spoolie is going to just
angle your hairs and it's going to give
you a little bit of that moisture to
move it around and
then you can sort of bush it out and you
can either make a very specific line and
you can
arch it very smooth or you can jack it
out
and do something
a little more
you know
i need jazzy start tweezing
around that
i love it you can see the difference you
can yeah you can totally see it yeah
really 100 you should
do that
do it every day but also
do both i was gonna say maybe you should
do the other one too all right
guess what um it's your story ross
all right i'll work on the other side
she evens out her face our next question
comes from michelle who's also in our
audience where are you michelle right
here hi welcome to the show thank you
love darling
okay how can we it's time to ask a
desperate how can we help i have a
question about a jewelry trend so i know
pearls are a new trend that's happening
right now um and i love wearing my
pearls but i want to know like am am i
doing the trend right am i like i only
wear it for special occasions but
i'd like to be able to do it all the
time michelle we actually have the
perfect desk spurt here to answer this
question for you he actually rocked his
pearls all the way to the world series
please welcome
outfielder for the world champion
atlanta braves
jack petersen
look they're standing for you
thank you thank you
i have to tell you we are so thrilled
that you are here um what gave you the
idea to wear pearls where does the love
come from and what made you go for it
uh yeah great question i don't know i
always thought they just kind of looked
good i saw
justin bieber and uh machine gun kelly i
think wear them to like the espys or
something and i don't know they're kind
of on top of their style so i reached
out to my jeweler
and wanted to change things up a little
bit and uh i think the white looks good
with the jerseys honestly better than
the gold chain and the black so
i just went for it shooter shoot what
did your teammates think of the whole
pearl look on the field
uh
yeah they were making fun of me for sure
but it's all right i thought they look
good and i think that's all that matters
and then uh i love that i think they
were probably pretty shocked when uh
i don't know the braves in atlanta kind
of took it by storm and everyone started
wearing pearls so then i think a couple
guys asked me actually they said oh you
know i actually
i kind of like that where do you get
where did you get those from i'm i might
get it
look what you started you even got ross
matthews putting on a
a set what do you think there you go
i have to i have to agree um with
michelle though there are a lot of
interpretations of
the pearl and i was just curious
do you have any advice for michelle do
you have a particular length or layering
or simplicity what is your desk spurt
opinion
i've only done one i got one
and uh i tried to keep it simple with
that um but yours looks good uh you have
a you have a lot going on there and uh
and if you look good and you feel you
look good that's all that matters oh
come on
what a great
what a great pearl of wisdom thank you
for that
sounds good chuck peterson thank you so
much
[Music]